Hi, my, boo!
Hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi, hi.
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
Will be cannibalism in this stream?
Never say never.
Howdy, welcome, and welcome, welcome.
Probably.
It ain't a minke stream without some cannibalism, am I
right?
Am I right?
Just got off work.
Oh, too.
Oh, too, oh, too, oh, too.
Good job, everybody.
If you are working right now.
If you are working right now, keep on it.
You got this.
It's almost the weekend.
And if you just got off work, oh, too.
You did so good job.
Wait, you did so good today.
thanks for coming in thanks for joining hi everybody we're
playing the brand new chillas art game today that i did the
demo for what was it called again oh my gosh umigari
i forgot it i forgot i forgot cannibalism is okay if you
only eat vegetarians would that that wouldn't make you a
vegetarian no the umi garmi killer no well thank you so much
for the thank you thank you and and and and invisible moose
thank you so much for the tag gifted hello minto and i boo's
like you the job site today has been very nasty and mean to
me stream will give me through the rest of the day let's
fish minto i'm ready to fish baby chill a slop oh yeah you
know what i think i'm a slop enjoyer because you know some
people will you know like bowls like okay bowls like uh like
uh okay hold on you go to a you go to a restaurant yes like
a bowl slop you know you know like a chipotle yeah kind of
kind of like the food yeah yeah a place where you can be
like i want to go get i want to go get a i don't know what a
bowl of i want to go get a meat bowl i kind of love bowl
slop so i truly think i'm a slop enjoyer and you know what
that's fine if it's tasty i don't care chill a slop but the
demo for this one was pretty fine so i'm excited that's what
I was sorry if you were looking forward to to high tail I
don't know I'm finding myself enjoying high tail but my
complaint with it is it's really grindy and it's kind of
difficult solo I've been like playing some games by myself
like my own world by myself and it's yeah so I don't know
high tail ain't done yet I yeah I am really really looking
forward to them adding more stuff not that it's doesn't have
enough stuff already um but like seeing what else they add
to it so yeah how is portal oh my god oh my god i am playing
portal 2 right now to um record some some uh streams that i
can upload while i'm gone uh next month i will still be
streaming next month but they'll be just lesser stream so in
between the days that I can't stream I wanted to um have
some some playthrough for you and I I don't know I feel like
I might try and do a second game but it really depends on my
schedule because I feel like I'm kind of getting through the
game quickly I don't know maybe the chapters will be well
maybe it'll be longer in the end but hey me though I caught
a nasty cold yesterday and it's wearing me down today you
wouldn't happen to have a feel Marino!
Of course, I always have a feel better beam for you!
My, my feel better beam!
And then the feel better beam was so big, it covered the
entire earth and everybody felt better.
everybody was happy and felt better the end it's my birthday
yesterday i was just wondering if i get a happy birthday
happy birthday i'm so sorry i missed your birthday yesterday
let's just rewinding to yesterday happy birthday happy happy
birthday i thought you were gonna say everybody died in the
end no I do feel better.
Wow.
Yippee!
Yay!
What was I gonna say?
I was gonna say...
Oh, Portal!
Oh my gosh.
I'm on chapter 7 out of 9.
And I've only recorded four parts so far.
Four one-hour parts.
So I'm like, I thought that it would be, there's been a few
puzzles that have stumped me.
It's like one every part.
There's like one puzzle that I'm like, oh my gosh, there was
one yet, like there was one that, I was like, I don't get
it.
I don't know, how am I supposed to do this?
I was trying everything and I completely overlooked this
button that I needed to press and I felt so stupid.
so it's not super long yeah but a lot of the things said
like an average of eight to nine hours like that's the
average how long to be and i'm at chapter seven and i'm at
four hours in so i don't know i don't know you can edit it
out make and act like you're a genius no you're gonna have
to live through all of the suffering of me trying to figure
out these puzzles all on my own while you yell at screen and
you're like no vtuber do this and i can't hear you la la la
it's all you just gonna have to watch the process i mean
that was my birthday wish but happy birthday happy birthday
good fish and been listening to your karaoke of evermore on
loop this morning and the minto disney princess allegations
have only become stronger in my eyes good luck with the game
i love I love evermore.
I love it, I love it.
Something about your voice is so mesmerizing.
Sometimes I focus so much on the voice that I miss what you
actually said.
That's what bonds are for, huh?
Really?
I actually don't like my voice so much, so...
If you guys like it, that's really good.
I mean, I would hope that you like it because you're
listening to it for a time so thanks for the healing beam
i've been sick for the last week it's my birthday today also
gonna get a happy birthday as well pretty please error 404
happy birthday happy birthday happy birthday oh now i want
to do a i've been wanting to kind of like itch for like a
karaoke but i want to like i feel like i always do the same
songs and then i Like, I haven't had time.
I've been, like, practicing for the jazz show.
I don't know.
Like, I always sing the same songs.
But I've been just...
And also, I don't want to sing.
And, like, wear out my voice.
For the show.
So, I don't know.
But we like those same songs.
Yeah, me too.
That's why I keep singing them.
Yeah, so I love your voice.
How long did it take for those voice bags?
I know.
But, like, at the same time.
Oh, well.
I feel like that's so many people, though, that are just
like, Oh, I don't like my voice.
I don't like how it sounds.
I feel like that's a lot of people.
And I'm not talking about, like, a singing.
I'm talking about just, like, speaking and hanging out.
Oh, my gosh.
I've been having so many issues with my um my all a a I a I
oh I always want to call it an aoi but it's a aio and it's
because it's it like um flickers like crazy and it gets
pretty distracting when I'm streaming I'm like looking at it
right now but right now it's not flashing at all and you
usually it's only when my computer is like hardcore like
going crazy like pumping it up that that it stops flickering
your water cooling ai yeah yeah yeah it has like a little
screen on it and when i am when i am playing like it's so
funny because chilla's art games are notoriously unoptimized
So it's going to be like, it's going to be like, how old?
No, it's not old at all.
I got this maybe like a year and a half ago.
Where do I get tickets for your show me, though?
Is there a linky that I can clicky?
Yes!
Um, there is.
Oh.
Dark Rids, thank you so much for the fun.
Get it.
What is it?
Hold on.
When I click out of the game.
It stops the sound.
Sorry.
There are streaming tickets!
How?
Who?
I will pin streaming streaming tickets streaming tickets for
my 3D jazz show here.
And I'll even pin it.
Sorry, other pinned message.
Hi Minto, hi chat!
Hi Reese!
Hello!
Thank you so much for listening for time!
Ta-da!
There are streaming tickets.
So, yeah.
And how bad is UK time gonna be if...
you have like weeks to watch it so you know you don't have
to watch it at the same time real fast oh my gosh thank you
so much for the 50 gifted thank you thank you thank you so
much thank you game dub station welcome welcome did you
forget the hat my hat wait a second i should put on my hat
right we need my hat my fishing hat there we go now i feel
like a true Krusty Krab employee.
Whimsy, thank you so much for the fight, get that.
Why are there so many gifts?
Gifts.
This is just a box.
Welcome back.
Unreal citizen, thank you for the Akasamo.
It's not like we love your voice or anything.
Thank you.
You can, Ireland, get it at 4.
4 a.m.
Crazy.
You could have the earliest start to your Saturday.
Koharu Nendo Picks.
I know!
Oh my gosh.
Koharu Nendoroid got the pictures and the pre-orders are up.
But I can't pre-order yet.
Pre-order it.
Because it comes out in July.
I will be moved.
I don't have a new address!
So I have to hope that...
I mean, I'm sure I'll be able to get her...
Some after.
I will.
But...
I'd have to wait a little bit.
I'd have to wait a little bit until I can get her.
Send it to a PO box.
Ship it to the dentist.
I didn't even consider that.
I can make them ship it to me.
Wait a second, wait a second.
This is what having a manager is all about.
Actually, I applied for some tickets for an idol show.
And the only way that I could apply for the tickets was if I
said that I would pay at a convenience store.
Like at a convenience.
And obviously I'm not in Japan.
the moment so i cannot pay but i was like well this is what
having a manager is all about right ask vicky oh my god wait
a second
i feel bad asking friends so i ask the person that i pay i
was like do you know anybody in japan because wait a second
i feel bad asking my friends though
what if i asked steiner i was like hey um can you like can
you find someone to go get these for me wait a second this
is what having a manager is all about me though toy toy toy
toy toy i can't say that
Torturing!
Let's just play this damn game, okay!
Hopefully, hopefully it doesn't crash my computer.
Oh my gosh!
Whoa, we're awake!
Catch fish, selfish, refuel, head to shrine!
Whoa, the sensitivity kind of feels like crazy in here.
I turned it to I was like 1920 by 1080 let's like let's turn
down the resolution and everything oh wait maybe it's under
oh my gosh I have a funny story from yap yap before yap yap
wait hold on where was it before yap yap because I was going
through these I was like turning everything from ultra to
high because I don't trust these games oh before yap yap um
it was uh it was me and doki and nimi uh in the call and we
were we were the the fov for that game with starting out was
insane it was so like whoa like whoa like crazy i felt like
i was in a void and like the sensitivity was also like
insane let's do it let's do like half and so doki and i we
were like like doki and i were in the call first and we were
i was like whoa oh my gosh what is this what what am i being
teleported to and um i changed it to like 70 ish or
something oh gosh wait what was this just at oops wait it's
fine right yeah okay um i changed it to like 70 or something
because i prefer like more i don't i don't need to see the I
don't need to be like a fishbowl, right?
And so Doki did the same.
And then Nimi was just like, yeah, I cranked mine all the
way up.
And I was like, what do you mean you cranked it all the way
up?
And she was like, yeah, I'm at 100 and something.
And I was like, what?
90 to 120 is the standard?
No, I'm telling you.
Oh, let's see what it looks like.
110.
Oh, actually, this is.
look so bad but i'm telling you with the other game it was
like i wish i could show you this actually looks normal this
is wait what the heck is going on with the water here um
hello what is happening here no money oh selling yeah yeah i
remember how to do all this i always crank it up or i get
nauseated this actually looks normal but i'm telling you the
other game if you look at my pov okay wait a second though
actually i want your opinion then for anybody that watched
my pov and also watched nimmy's pov which do you prefer
which which did you prefer i think i had mine at like 70 or
something um i
didn't don't don't be mean nimmy is mine nimmy is no it's
not it's not a hate to nimmy i think it's just like i'm also
trying to it's like i'm conducting research at the moment
you're pulling a biased audience here you guys are all
getting me wrong i'm not saying do you prefer me or nimmy
that's literally not what i said at all i said did you
prefer nimmy's fov or my fov not not a not a my pov versus
her pov don't get it twisted don't get it twisted Oh my
goodness.
FOV, you guys, FOV!
You know what?
Never mind.
A lot of you guys, I think, just don't understand.
Oh my god.
Anyway, let's fish.
Oh, these you can collect for money too.
Wait, how do I collect it for money?
Collect it for money.
How do I collect that?
Wait, that was totally a thing before I remember.
Did it just go, ugh!
Did she just go, ugh?
Maybe.
Why is the water like this?
Uh, cute.
Nah, did I just say 500 yen?
Let's go.
I remember the bigger fish being over here.
You're my best field of view.
Let me go.
I like the view.
Ooh, that one was bloody.
They're my best.
I feel.
Isn't it feel the vision?
Wait, am I...
I thought it was a vision.
Wait, is it view?
Wait a second.
Which is it?
Aren't these pufferfish here?
Wait, I remember the puffer...
I blacked out.
I remember the pufferfish being ginormous.
Why is it so blurry?
though.
Do I need glasses or maybe I just don't know how to
stupid fisherman hasn't adjusted to the salt water doesn't
know how I can't open my eyes in in water.
Can you guys in salt water?
The
heck is going on here!
Guys, I think something paranormal is happening.
I think there are some people that can, right?
in salt water it's like it feels insane yes but it stings
wait I thought I could grab these before hmm wait there's
actually quite a few different stuff than the demo like all
of this over there was not there before oh oh
I'm pressing E but it just flips it over okay they took out
my extra money.
No!
I was making big bucks on the shelves!
Oh!
There's just no propped for it.
Oh, you still can!
There's just no propped!
I'm silly.
She ate clams.
Not really a clam gal, though.
How could you miss?
Oh my gosh!
Right now we're just making the bucks.
Lie detected.
About clams?
No, I actually don't.
I'm really... I honestly just...
There's...
I'm pretty picky about my seafood.
Mmm.
Alright, big fish.
Big fish coming in.
Big fish over here.
I guess we can...
Oh!
I was gonna say, I guess we don't need to breathe, but...
Oh yeah.
Do you like crab sticks?
I like crab.
I'm
like...
Um...
I'm kind of picky.
Oh.
Oh wait, I know how to hunt.
Hmm.
Leave it on the boat and I'll buy it.
Don't drive rough, though.
The fish will fall out.
You only find pufferfish.
That's a lie because I found more.
Bring me the goodies and I'll upgrade your boaty.
Bring me a load, all right?
Okay, okay.
Sell.
Yeah, see the tuna?
Nice.
Harpoon reel.
It says one out of one.
Maybe we should just upgrade these for now, then.
We'll upgrade all of our stuff first, like our harpoon
things first, and then we can get to the boat.
I'll hand over the map to you.
Make good use of it, all right?
Okay, thank you.
Oh, oh, thank you.
Open our clothes with M key.
So we got a refuel.
I'm going to sell some more stuff, though.
Yeah, don't forget fuel.
Minto's voice is unique.
You are on.
Whether singing, chattering, or shouting, idols chance.
Your voice energizes me.
Thank you!
I do hear that, though, that my voice is recognizable, which
is kind of fun.
What's up with the water here?
Like it's over there, too.
Acting all funky.
Wait, you think I can walk there?
It's all rock.
Let's try it.
Yeah, seems shallow, right?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
All right, we go put...
Oh, wait, I can sprint.
Sorry, I forgot that I could do that.
I was...
Since I've been playing Portal and you can't sprint, I
keep...
I was like, oh, I just don't need to hold down the button.
Oh!
Ah!
Oh, we were so close!
I think you do technically have, like, a breath, you know?
Like it's an invisible breath meter.
Not a weird dream like...
Oh, what a weird dream like game.
Random merchant on a tiny...
Tiny...
I can't speak today.
Tiny island just for you.
Gash pump in the sand.
Windmills for some reason.
It's honestly, if there weren't a horror game, I feel like
the aesthetic is like really nice.
The aesthetic for the game is like pretty nice, I'd say.
Okay.
cozy horror
it makes me I can't wait for summer it's so cold lately I'm
so cold I usually turn all my games to 110 FOV but I do have
friends that talk about lower FOV helping with their motion
sickness but this doesn't seem very bad to you guys right
I've turned off motion blur so I think it's not so bad I
feel like it's This is actually...
I'm telling you, if you see the different POVs from me and
Nimi, you'll understand probably what I'm talking about.
It seems... I think it was... Oops.
I think it was more dramatic in that game than it is in this
game.
Okay, I'm gonna jump.
Alright, we're gonna get a head start.
Watch this.
Ah!
Okay.
It hates us, it hates us.
Nice hot.
Thank you!
Can I go here?
No.
I'm testing all the boundaries of...
The game.
Excuse me!
Shop.
Sell.
How much is it to refill?
Ah!
Okay.
We could go to the shrine.
We could head out on the road.
We could...
Get driving.
Visit the...
Return to the last gas station you visited.
I think that gets rid of all of your stuff, though.
Oh, whoops.
I'm driving.
I think that gets rid of all the fish, though.
Oh!
We're about to go get ourselves a girl.
Are there any fish here?
Wow, clear.
Nice.
Hakure shrine.
So true.
Some of these fish are making sounds that I think are
suspicious.
I think that's puffer fish.
Wait a second, I think I see some bigger fish over here.
Some bigger fish to fry.
If you get sick from games, VR, or any sort of media, it
means your eyes...
Wait.
You use your eyes a lot for your sense of motion and
balance.
You can overcome this by blinding yourself.
I thought you had some actual advice here.
Those are normal fish noises.
True, I've been fishing.
before.
I was like, oh, this is good.
Some people will need this advice, you know.
Oh my gosh, the blood is insane.
Can we jump out here?
Okay.
I learned.
But it's all rocks!
My boats are gonna get stuck!
Maybe I should have gone through the gate, like a proper I'm
a heathen at the moment.
Like, this is so nice.
This is so...
Like, the sounds of the ocean and...
Well, the girl's there.
She's asleep.
I'll turn it up for you guys soon.
More money.
And also...
Who is this?
It's... someone.
Pretty shells.
And some money.
I wonder if Doki is still going to be in these games.
The water is still kind of funky.
Alright.
Let's go get that girl.
Oh.
I'm robbing the shrine.
It's probably really bad luck.
Bad luck.
Hello.
Oh.
Are you okay?
I have to hurry to end the curse to get to that island as
soon as possible.
Who took the three stone tablet shards to fit into this
door?
I need them to open this door so that I can get to that
island.
I can't do this alone.
Will you help me?
I have to find the tablet.
Oh no, she's an iPad kid!
Oh, jeez.
Oh, is she on my boat?
Yeah, there she is.
Place three tablet shards into the shrine door near First
Island.
Oh, okay, so this is all new.
It's fun.
Oh, my God.
Our boat is so sensitive.
You're still there?
Okay, so are my fish?
Ma'am, we might take some detours to fish.
I'm just warning you now.
Especially as I see these big fish over here.
one moment mama needs money you
okay maybe she gets motion sickness too wait wait wait mama
needs money no no there oh that was don't worry about it
don't worry about the sound
oh no I hope that's not you.
Quick, pick up my harpoon.
Quick.
Uh-oh.
Here's some money, mama.
Thank you.
We're docking.
And we're leaving.
And hold on, I'm getting this fish over here first.
She's a professional, everybody.
She's a professional.
I kind of missed in the demo the fish were, like, so
unnaturally oversized.
What is this?
Apply paint!
What changed?
Oh!
Oh, it's lovely!
I love Rush
Yeah About the fish here Seems like they're all puffer fish
and tuna around here Go catch a bunch for me, okay?
Okay, I thought he was gonna I thought I was asking about
the The anime boy and girl noises that they make Select all
and sell baby sell All right, we need to really fill up our,
like, fuel capacity and speed and stuff, because that will
really hurt you.
So, as the ship speed increases, fuel consumption also
rises.
So what's the point, then?
Yeah, I was asking about the ooze.
And the ooze.
Ooz.
You increase the capacity to compensate.
Yeah, but like...
I mean, I will get that first, honestly.
Umigari equals return to the sea.
I remember that from Forbidden Siren Games.
Umigari.
A little different.
What does the hat say?
I need that clipper to make more compilation of it.
That clipper.
Oh, oh.
The fish just went into the sand.
Oh, there he is.
It's going to be a little bit of a grind in the beginning as
I...
Because...
Wait, what's our...
Oh, yeah.
Our mission at the moment is like finding the tablets.
I know there's some stuff over there, so...
My hat says...
Women fear me, fish fear me, men turn their eyes away from
me as I walk.
No beast dares make a sound.
In my presence I am alone.
barren earth oh
let's sell this guy and we'll fill up too how woman me too
oh no dang it no don't get me sick please sell select all
sell okay all right we won't do the speed for now we're just
gonna go wait we have a place we can go to real quick.
This one is right by us.
Swimmy.
Oh,
gosh.
The water is all sorts of screwed up here as well.
The windmills.
Yeah, in the demo, the windmills were the only thing you
could go to.
So, um, well, okay.
Help.
Oh, my God.
Help?
Um, hold on.
I think I can get back into my boat.
Yeah.
Okay, good, good.
Um, let's get a little closer.
That should be good.
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh!
Oh, these are things that I've...
This guy is just in a Gengar hat.
He's in a Gengar hat.
Oh, these are like the supporter things.
Oh, look how many there are.
That looks like a puffer fish.
Is it meant to look like this on purpose or is it just
glitchy as all heck?
I don't know.
I feel like it's probably a...
No, no, no, no.
I feel like it's probably a glitch.
Any special...
Oh, dang it.
I was going to say any special, uh...
What's the words?
Oh yeah, it's definitely not supposed to be like this.
Um, any special shells.
But anyway, let's go to the windmills.
Look, there's even like a little house here.
And be on the lookout for some larger fish, you know.
We didn't go out very far, but be on the lookout.
It's a me, Takashi.
You can just walk under the water if you jump through the
glitch, maybe?
Alright, I know, I remember I think we had to do this to get
it to move.
And I think there was something at the top of it.
Or maybe there's something at the top of that one.
Regardless, there's special stuff.
There's something special.
I played the demo.
I'm an expert at this game.
Oh, oopsie.
That looked like a flying fish.
I just saw a real catch in the bottom right.
Bottom.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, I overestimated that like crazy.
I also think that they made it so you lose gas less easily
maybe i might be eating those words but it feels like it i
feel like before i couldn't go to this area without feeling
like i was really um about to like not make it you know what
i mean oh that's a big one
you're the catch i'm not a fish
Wait, what?
Oh my gosh, that scared me.
Holy cow!
That scared me.
Let's go get our thing.
Our upgrade, baby!
Our upgrade, upgrade.
Can I grab that?
I just harpoon it?
Uh.
Uh, it won't let me drop it.
Uh-oh, wait.
Can I drive?
And drop it?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
No, no.
Oh, pick up?
Give the bell to the fishmonger.
Oh!
What did I do?
Huh?
Oh,
I think I got hit.
Oh, let's not get hit again.
I think.
Wait, is that it?
Oh, God.
What's happening?
What is going on?
Wait, are these some big fish?
Big fish?
Ooh, ooh.
We're little fish.
eyes detected in the bottom right as i can never turn my
eyes away from minto and i extra couldn't when she's walking
what is what are you talking about oh i found a bell you got
a bell the big monster umiga can't stand the sound of that
bell see that red buoy that one over there well where it
like that.
Oh, that's where it goes.
Alright, I'll go attach it.
See?
Nice, huh?
Strike the buoy bell with your harpoon to make it ring.
Why can't I keep it on my boat and ring it myself?
Looks like all the bells I had on the buoys went missing
somehow.
Bring them back and I'll fix things up for you.
But out there, I'm not sure if it's because of Amiga's curse
or what, but you cannot use boost.
So it won't be easy.
Steal yourself and give it your way.
all.
I've marked the places that you can reach on your map.
If you run into Umiga, don't forget to ring the bell.
Got it?
Find the missing bells to the buoys between islands and
you'll reach new areas.
Keep it up, yeah?
Huh.
I see.
Wait.
It says zoom.
Okay, close.
Can you take my stuff now?
Shop.
Oh, well, the upgrades Oh man.
Oh wait, no, we just got the boost added.
Love how we point the harpoon casually at the merchant when
talking to him.
Yeah, you know.
All right, let's do our boat speed.
I suppose for now.
How do I boost on my boat?
I think I was supposed to get a tutorial and I didn't get
anything.
is called
never once in all my years of life someone marked a location
on my map i'm starting to feel like a weird overcarrying
whatever yeah you know like i've had my stuff marked on a
map i don't know what's up with you so were these islands
that we can go to like the the tori gate or
something i guess we'll pin towards that way right
more money oh it's like so obvious it's like there's your
pin head that way i don't want to get attacked oh shift is
to boost okay cool boat speed level one required
am i good are you gonna deny me or i'm scared
saw i heard what was happening and i just i just i backed up
very very quickly gonna turn it down just a bit because it
sounded kind of loud all right let's go in and i guess i
have to ring the so we can't boost in here is that what it
was and we have to ring this
i think that got rid of them I think that did the trick.
Potentially.
I don't think so!
I don't think that did the trick!
Oh, okay, we're fine.
Okay, that's a mechanic that they added to the game.
Okay.
Definitely is...
Oh, make sure to save your progress.
The game warns you when you when you um when you start that
it does not auto save at all so if you lose if you like die
i guess that's it like we don't want the game to crash or
anything on us either so we shall um yeah remember it was
pretty difficult to get here like i felt like i was i was
grinding like crazy to get all the way out here in the demo
and now we're just like cruising along made that a um oh is
that guy uh update
yeah you needed multiple boat upgrades for sure yeah yeah i
was like i was like struggling i was like struggling like
hardcore i felt
4 000
you were like us right so you know what this feels like Just
stop, please.
It spoke to me.
My money spoke to me.
Yeah, was I a fish?
Turned human?
What do they mean by that?
Anything?
There's this.
I thought this would definitely be a place you could go
inside in this game.
But in the final version I spoke.
I meant.
But you can't crouch either.
I'm also the tallest person alive.
Is it my...
Is it my F-O...
No, this is a really short door.
What is happening?
This is normal.
What the heck?
We have like a doggy door for the convenience.
Sorry, I'm looking for what other fish we got over here.
Oh, what's that?
What are you?
It's...
It begins.
It's a tuna!
It's just a tuna!
I arrived a new area.
So you actually made it this far, huh?
and managed to get away from Mumiga, huh?
Not bad.
Alright then, keep it up, yeah?
What are you laughing about?
Yeah, I brought some fish.
This guy is Buku Bucks.
Oh, timid fish.
They're worth a little bit more.
Nice.
Wait, about the fish here?
The fish here are kind of shy, you know?
If you make eye contact, they'll run off so grab them quick
before they bolt oh they're so shy or maybe they're like
terrified of you know
oh hello is that in the umiga area or no that's in our area
the beast
let's do some upgrades let's do let's do our harpoon
and boost cool down seems kind of important I think having a
lower cool down is usually we're gonna farm some of it I
think we well I don't know how much I feel like they've
changed so much from the demo so I'm not gonna go into the
school right yet nice I am a professional because I don't
know if like it will it'll cause anything to happen you know
what I mean Do you think I can reach that?
Holy!
That might be the greatest!
Gamer Am!
My aim bot is on, baby.
My aim bot is on!
Get under the water.
Oh, never mind.
The blackout gets me every time.
Oh, I just realized that that...
Oh, did these?
These look like...
Pieces of...
I don't know what they looked like.
They looked like pieces of moss or something to me, so I
didn't even think that they were...
Oh.
Dang it!
Yeah, I think they may be...
Oh, he's still out there.
You see him?
Uh...
I think they might be a little...
No.
Students...
Ah, huge shark.
Students that don't want to get...
Got...
Oh my god.
Now they're getting annoying.
Oh, he's right there!
Oh, he's swimming under the island.
I got half of his health down, though.
Where'd he go?
Where did he go?
Wait, why did he make that?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't think I would struggle so much with these guys, but
they're kind of annoying.
I know that you're like, students turn fish, but like, could
you please cooperate with me?
No, I don't want normal tuna.
I need the big money.
Take it.
Where'd that big guy go?
That's the school principal.
Dang.
Alright, so I guess we don't have to go back through there
if we ever don't want to, which is kind of nice.
Do appreciate a fast travel option to have.
Ah!
Nice.
Oh, there he is!
He'll probably come back.
He'll be back.
They're so cute, though, in their little Seifuku.
He's so cute.
And they're also cute because they give me money.
Only roaming, too.
That guy.
Money is cute.
Hmm.
It's not like I want to get caught or anything, S-S-Sanpai!
Going to school and you get speared?
Do you think like they were inspired by a school of fish?
Do you think?
plus two plus two don't say minus two no it's good you know
it it's so good you know it
how does this guy get through the the big the big scary
monster i guess he also rings the bell minus 10 aura i've
always been negative aura you don't scare me you don't
affect me there he is a wonder oh i feel like i was close
wait a second he's gonna get close though he's gonna get
close
i could probably chase him chase after him in my boat but i
feel like i should oh you know what well he's kind of far
now I'm just gonna say do the upgrades first.
This is a good try.
Thank you.
I'm trying.
Hey, what the heck?
You're not a timid fish.
You are, though.
We're getting lots of safe...
Oh, I was gonna say we're getting lots of safe Fuku girls.
But actually, we're getting all the boy uniforms instead.
Is that one?
Are you a fish?
Maybe not.
I'm in the market for a new office chair.
Minto, what chair do you use?
I'm kind of short, guys, so I figured you'd have similar
ergonomics.
First of all...
Actually, though, my chair...
I've kind of talked about it before.
It's like...
It's not...
I don't use, like, a regular office chair.
chair because I'm oh that was terrible I'm often like
sitting in such bizarre positions like if you guys could see
the way I'm sitting right now you might be like what the
hell there he is no
come on come on I had him I had him he's just Zerklund.
Gollum.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, maybe.
Hover guy, welcome to Membushhip.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, like, um...
Right now...
Okay, I'm gonna say something that...
I don't know if I've ever said this on stream before.
And I was worried about saying it because...
put any ideas into your heads.
I have a friend who, she was like, oh my gosh, my kid loves
watching you.
And I was like, uh-oh, why?
Like, he's a younger kid.
She was like, my kid loves watching you.
And, um...
But she was like, one day, uh...
He was watching your stream with one of his friends over and
the friend's mom happened to see the stream and was just
like, this is so inappropriate.
Why are her legs like that?
And my friend was like, what?
And the mom thought that my arms.
my mom thought that my arms like this were my knees and then
i'm just spread eagle the entire stream
i was like my friend had to be like my friend was just like
because it was just like very normal stream that i that they
were watching She was like, it was not inappropriate at all.
Because she's a ghost.
And so, my friend was just like, what do you mean
inappropriate?
Like, obviously, I don't think I'm like, you know, I'm a
kid's channel or anything.
But, you know, I was like, my friend was just very confused.
That was the reasoning.
No, please, I have been sitting, I have not told you guys
this for a really long time because I was like, I was like
so embarrassed about it.
I was like, I really don't want to put this idea to you
guys' head.
I can't unsee that.
Shut up, man.
But please, if you do art like that, I don't want to see it.
Only put it in the R18 tag, okay?
I mean, fandom parental discretion is not advised.
I could not have arrived at a more perfect time to hear that
story.
Oh, God.
It was so embarrassing.
I've never, ever thought of it in that world.
before I was like wait a second there's no way there's no
way let's do the boost duration as well okay we do need to
up the speed and stuff too but we'll we'll go with this for
now we'll head to the wait why is my I thought I added I
thought I maxed out oh because I just I increased my whoa I
increased my capacity that's That's why.
That's why.
All right, we'll park right here.
Oh, oops.
Save before entering the school?
So you're so right.
Oh my gosh, you're so right.
This is why I'm here.
Clips like these.
Time to draw.
No!
It's so embarrassing.
Oh, oh, oh, it's got a nerve.
Think of it like this.
It was that lady who thought of the pose, so, so, of that
pose for you.
So how filthy is her mind?
Arms back up, me, don't be proud.
You know what?
I am a ghost.
I'm a ghost and I'm proud.
I just thought it was so out of pocket.
I was like, my friend telling me that, she was like, sorry,
this might be really embarrassing, but like...
How do I...
Okay, I was gonna take off the pin.
Yeah, it was pretty embarrassing.
Say it loud!
I'm a ghost and I'm proud!
Oh.
That's this way.
I see something shining over there.
I feel maybe...
Oh, wait.
Oops.
That's fine, actually, because I was going to go back.
Wait, I saw...
There.
A shell.
I know they barely give you any yen, but I don't care.
Money is money.
I just can't.
I have a hard time, like, if I'm, if I'm like, how do I say?
So for example, if I am thinking of something in a certain
way, I have a very hard time imagining it as something else.
You know what, so for example, like, I'll use humor.
Morris as an example.
I, because I read, I see the text Hugh Morris.
I can't my brain does not hear the the, the, the, the pun.
Helsing game.
Love that guy.
She must have been on some freaky stuff because I still
can't see it.
And you know what?
That's great.
If you can't see it, That's the best.
That's the best ending.
So, you know, if I'm like...
If someone was just like, yeah, his name is Hugh Morris.
I'm like, oh yeah, Hugh Morris.
Okay.
Yeah, like I... I... It's hard for me to...
Oh, wait.
Um...
Sorry.
I just realized that, like...
I don't have a way to get you guys...
What is that one?
Oh, it's so hard to tell.
And that's why there's like, uh, like the, when they do the
puns of, like, the silly names that are, like, something
actually kind of explicit.
It's hard for me to, what's that?
It's hard for me to hear it.
Oh.
That one name Ace Attorney cannot use now.
I know, right?
They totally lost out.
Oh, everything was a Lord of the Lord of the Lord.
What does that sound?
Maybe it's upstairs.
Oh, what's this?
Oh.
I sound.
Oh no!
Our spoils are gone!
There's nothing over here.
Q.
Morris.
If this weren't a horror game, I swear, it's such good
vibes.
Such good vibes.
What are we doing in here again?
I mean, I know one of our thing is a...
We have a tab.
The three tablet shards.
I think I remember a huge head here.
Yeah, I do remember that part.
Ooh, it's still there.
Creepy.
Remember you from the demo.
Wait, was there anything over here?
Wait!
Ah, I remember the characters with like the...
The different... We have to, like, bring them up here, don't
we?
Oh.
Oh!
It's this guy walking around!
That's what all that sound is.
This is just plop, plopping around.
Gross.
Picked up something.
They're so fun to look at.
Hold on.
I don't... He didn't do anything before, but just in case.
I'm coming to you.
And I'm taking your stash.
I'm taking your whole stash.
Nice.
Tunjijito stuff.
Yeah, I know, right?
Is there anything up here?
A ladder that I cannot climb.
Look at how much passive income we've made, guys.
Just from walking around.
Oh, yeah.
It's like 100 yen each.
I think that's it, actually.
I wish I had parked my boat.
Take it.
Ooh, that one's special looking.
Give it to me through the board.
Wait, am I stuck in here?
Ah!
Wait, can I go back up?
Oh, we can't go back up!
Okay, good, good, good.
Phew.
Hello.
What's this?
Oh, come on.
Oh, I got a thing for my boat.
Updated map!
Do you think the purple is that big guy?
That big fish?
Wait.
It's behind me.
oh maybe oh yeah I think so I think so he is right behind me
isn't he I am reborn God didn't abandon me there were
bullies in my class I know because I was was always watching
them from the fish tank some classmates were kind to me they
even fed me through the glass but the bullies tormented the
ones who cared for me.
I'm part of the class too.
I'll make sure those jerks are dealt with.
You see the desks in front of me?
They're the accessories the bullies wear.
So yeah, we gotta go get the fish of the bullies.
Place three fish on the desk.
Alright.
Sorry, now that I'm remembering that I should save, I am.
And
you oh sorry oh whoa two for one so this guy was a fish and
then these these guys bullied him but he was a fish who
bullies oh i got three for one holy cat wait is this that's
a one yen
one yen a single yen I won't take it.
What were the, actually, what were the other accessories?
I think I remember the flowers.
Uh, this one.
She said, ita, ita!
Not enough for a single onigiri.
Literally, not enough for anything.
Can't even get a bubblegum for that.
You?
fish and then flowers all right a single yany i wonder
what's down here oh we can't go
i think because it's so relaxing oh i found another thing
it's so relaxing it kind of like has my guard lowered you
know what i mean Hello?
Just a lady.
I wonder if we can walk out here.
Oh, we can!
Can I go down?
I don't want to...
I don't want it to...
Spawn me back at the boat.
Alright.
Pink flower.
Oh!
I think it's...
That's the reason.
Okay.
cute that's we have to go back to the rooftop that's why
that's okay going through here was good anyway
I fell down there and then I completely forgot about that
being a thing oh I thought it was a sign it's just the way
the sun is it does look like it's pink
besides the big fish there hasn't been any horror.
Yeah, it's just been, I guess, like, I mean, there was the,
yeah, the big fish.
Just kind of feels unsettling, but nothing that has been
like.
Boom bam.
Which one is it?
Oh my gosh.
Oh my god.
Just calm down.
Calm down.
Yeah.
Let me grab you.
Let me fish you.
You're the fish now.
How's it feel?
Something's not right.
Aren't these the ones who were getting bullied?
Wait, which is which?
Alright, my apologies.
I have the memory of a goldfish, you see.
Either way, the weak must be consumed by the strong, yes?
Just like how I consumed my tank baits!
Now, if you'll excuse me.
It's chow-in time.
This guy is built.
Oh my god.
We got another bell.
I don't remember what we got in the demo.
Freaky.
Technically cannibalism?
Depends who you ask, huh?
Did I bring back any fish at all?
No.
Hello!
Brought back a fish trivia!
You know, goldfish are...
No way.
No.
There's a cannibalism in this game!
Reset the counter!
Counter!
Cannibalism has been mentioned!
Actually, not even just by me, by the game!
When they are starving, what do you gotta...
You do what you gotta do, right?
If humans had absolutely nothing to eat, maybe they'd do the
same.
Anyway, here's the bell.
Looks like you found the bell.
Hold up, I'll fix it right here.
up and mark the new places you can reach now good luck out
there oh nice okay cool we'll mark that but we will fast
travel to the first island you know i wonder if we can get
to these or maybe you have to have the bell to go through
the tori probably
very cool very cool but before we do that i do want to
upgrade my ship.
Dang it.
Oh, that was way too slow.
117.25 for cannibalism.
Good pace today, boss.
How soon will we get cannibalism?
It's like a new, it's the hit reality TV show.
All about cannibalism.
I'm gonna go after that big guy.
Dig in.
I'm about to run into the school.
Okay, he's...
I'm realizing he's like way fast.
He's like pretty fast.
For me.
But we do have other islands to see.
So that's kind of fun.
Look, we haven't been over here.
Why not?
What's this?
Okay.
We haven't been over here.
And there's more...
more fish to get.
He's fast though, he's really fast.
Faster than you anticipate, you know.
Ha!
Oh!
I didn't expect...
direction the fish went oh come on okay hold on we can get
like this guy oh i know i can get him i know i can get him
we're close we're close we can get this how do you notice
that i'm looking at you huh oh
come on it's like when you don't even know that someone's
looking at you you just feel it
You might get that feeling like when I'm around or
something.
Like someone's watching me.
I feel like somebody's watching me.
And I've got no privacy.
Oh well.
It happens a lot.
Have you considered that your place is haunted?
Dang it.
I didn't mean to look at you.
They're so timid.
That guy's not timid, though.
That guy's also only 500 yen, but...
Haunted.
Have you checked your home for ghost maids?
I know.
Ah, come on!
Dang it.
They're so shy.
Wait.
Ah,
I have to have my, like, my...
thing already.
What the?
Okay.
I have, like, supervision.
Stop being so shy!
I'm friend!
I'm your friend that you would loan a thousand yen!
Jokes on the invisible entities.
I like to be watched.
That could be the case, too.
There we go.
yes more money please more money please
oh come on
i wonder if that guy's health regenerates you know because
we got him like i feel like we got him pretty good
what does a ghost need with money it's all context i don't
need money But, I need money in the game.
And apparently fish need lots of money.
This guy is, like, charging me an arm and a leg for some of
this stuff.
Oh, that was so close, I feel.
The boat needs money.
The boat is a hungry machine.
A hungry machine she is.
my 100 yen seashell.
Oh my gosh.
It, like, I couldn't even see who it was.
Wait.
What the?
That didn't go at all where I directed it to.
Shaa.
Ooh, it took a nice sippy and it was like Ah!
Hello, I'm back.
Yes, shop, shop, shop.
Sell, sell, sell.
Upgrade.
Holy 90,000 for the fuel capacity next.
Good soda sounds.
They're so expensive.
Alright, we'll do the speed.
So we at least have one of everything there.
Let's go back to the main island.
Oh wow.
Oh, my bad.
We'll save though.
Oh, I guess.
I thought I was docked.
Hello!
Do you have anything new?
So can I buy the upgrades here?
Oh, I can!
Okay, that's pretty handy too then.
The real horror is the grind.
I'll be honest.
That's the part I don't mind.
I'm like, yeah, the grind.
It's kind of nice.
Just kind of like fishing along and, you know?
It's not so bad.
Let's see if there was anything over here.
but um I see the other Tori
is this the thing that I got before now it's like spinning
in the water what is this
it is why is it wait I'm so confused I have the boost I'm so
oh
oh I can't oh gosh I can't drop it again You guys I think
it's a glitch And now I can't use my harpoon Uh oh, um, this
is bad Wait a second Wait, this is bad I can't use my
harpoon Wait Uh, uh oh There's a seashell here And there's
something up there
Hmm This might be a problem
Survive being a bit of a problem.
Here's the current equivalent of 1,000 yen.
Thank you, Phil.
Thank you.
Take a swim?
Yeah, let's do that.
I think I have to reload.
It's a good thing I just saved.
Okay, we won't pick that back up.
Let's...
Head to the mall.
Wow, big fish!
I want that guy.
Alright, we're going to the mall, baby!
No way.
Did, like, the special seashells, they respawn.
Ooh, nice!
Okay.
Wait, do I have more paint?
Oh, that's what I've been collecting!
I just realized!
Oh.
Wow.
This is actually, like, really impressive.
To spray paint a...
It's, like, full wood.
Wait.
It's kind of incredibly impressive.
You could spray paint a boat to look like wood.
Okay, that's that one.
Oh.
Wow, it's even chipped and everything.
That's our Rusty, you guys.
This is so funny.
Wait, so this is a different Rusty.
Oh, yeah, this is different from before.
Wait, I like the blue.
Wow.
Oh.
A face only a mother could love.
Wow.
buh-bye buh-bye wait I'm going the right way right yeah yeah
yeah okay
isn't it pink
it's pink
for the engine it looked like there was an interaction above
the rudder but maybe not important
I mean I'm willing to try one more time, but at the same
time, I don't want, you know, all right, boat speed level
two required.
I had that, right?
I got that right.
I think I see it.
Yeah, there's the bell right there.
I'm gonna create a new save here.
All right, here we go.
It says speed level one.
Oh, wait, my speed level is wide.
Oh, yeah, it says right there.
Oh, you're right.
All right.
You're, I, okay.
We must then, okay.
We not must, but I'm gonna try this one more time.
Ouch.
And then we'll fast travel over to the, uh, to the other
island.
Wait, it's not even here.
It's not even here anymore.
It's such a strange phenomenon.
And there's another paint can here!
But I didn't grab because I had to resave.
Nice.
For Mama Man.
Phenomenon.
Oh, this way.
Fast travel.
Alright.
Fast travel to the school of fish.
Oh, we're docked.
Okay.
Let's get some money, baby.
Let's...
Let's... Let's get some big bucks.
Big fish.
You back there.
Yes.
I know I need to head to the mall, but I need the money
first.
Please.
Please understand.
I need the money first.
Where all the fish go?
Did they warn each other?
Are they like, she's out for a hunt?
You didn't even see that one?
I got the eye of an eagle, baby.
Eagle-eyed, mean toe.
That's what they call me.
That was an eagle.
That was an eagle sound.
Look, these all respawn.
Nice.
Passive income, baby.
Oh my god, that one saw me from all the way over here.
Don't be so dramatic.
Dang it.
No,
no, I got him.
I got him!
Okay, it does reset, though.
Oh, come on!
Oh, dang it.
Oh, I thought you would slow down for some reason.
Get him.
Should have, if only I were in my boat, you know.
If I were in my boat, I would have gone after him.
We'll get him.
Did I get him in the demo?
I can't remember.
If I got him then or not.
up i didn't yeah that makes sense i must have given up all
right we need a boat speed
hey guys it's my first time fishing could you just let me
catch you so that i don't i'm not an embarrassment to my
family thank you
my dad said that i can't have dinner if i don't catch a lot
of fish and i'm hungry oh dang yeah everybody pity me just a
little pity bite
a little pity bite here and there
these i think those seashells i like them so much it reminds
me that i'm like easter egg hunting so it's pretty fun
Selling, selling.
Boat speed.
We need the 15,000.
We're almost there.
We just need to catch, like, four more fish.
And we'll be good.
Oh.
Fish.
Fish probably sense the bloodthirsty aura.
What's the rollback button mean?
Curious.
Um, even if they do, uh, it should be like, uh, it should be
kind of like, you know how sometimes there's, I think that's
a regular fish, yeah?
Like, sometimes, uh, the aura will, will hypnotize the fish,
you know what I mean?
Or hypnotize the creature and make it like, like a moth to a
flame.
what I'm doing in my own way.
Where did all the fish go?
Oh.
Like a moth to a flame.
A fish to my harpoon.
Dang it.
Oh, oh, we just gotta stay in the area.
We just gotta stay in the area and we can get him.
Oh, nice.
Like a flame.
No.
Like a moth to a flame.
The fish to my harpoon.
Oof.
Eat a believe.
That guy will be back.
I don't know where he is now.
Wait, we can see him on the map.
We'll just wait in the water for him.
Dang it.
I was hoping they wouldn't have noticed.
Fish.
Oh, where do I need to go for?
Gosh, they're so good at noticing.
They're like, they take notice me, Senpai, like super
seriously.
You know what I mean?
Oh, dang it.
Dang it.
He could be here any second.
They're like, you ask, Senpai, and we know this.
Oh, come on.
He was right there.
Oh
no!
Wait, this is good.
You're still there, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello!
Hi!
Oh, golly!
Oh.
Wait, what just happened?
Oh, I got him!
I got him on the back of my ship!
Oh my gosh.
Nice!
Yeah!
I wonder if this guy respawns.
Hopefully this is like enough that we need, you know?
To...
Like...
10,000 giant tunnel!
Yippee!
Okay, upgrade.
Alright!
500!
50,000!
90,000!
Okay, the next fish better give us like 50,000 or 5,000 each
and all.
Holy cow.
There are IRL fish with human teeth.
I don't like that information.
I think I never wish to hear that.
Oh, uh...
Alright, now we can go to the next place.
Oh, whoops.
Uh, leaf.
Um...
What I'll... I think it's my boosting that means.
Caught a giant tuna.
Could that be?
You actually hauled that one up, huh?
That stone there.
Never mind.
Keep at it, you're doing good out there.
Wait, do I have one of the stones?
Is that what he just implied?
Yeah, we're gonna save.
Yes.
Nice.
And drive over here.
Parasite that will attach itself to a fish's tongue and over
time become the tongue.
They look kind of cute, actually.
Oh, we're zooming now.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
We're going to the mouth.
This is all new from here.
That's exciting.
It was in the mouth.
I don't think you grabbed it.
Oh, it's right here.
Oh!
Cool.
I saw it was in its...
Or I saw something was on it.
But yeah.
Alright, new save.
Let's go.
Alright.
The bell is there.
I'm scared.
I'm actually scared of this part.
Oh yeah, we can't boost in here.
I forgot.
Uh-oh.
Oops, I missed.
Oh, I didn't miss.
I didn't miss.
I thought I missed.
Okay, bye.
That would have been sooo embarrassing.
Make sure to save your progress!
I like that it does tell you.
Oh, are those flying fish?
Nice.
I'm docked.
I think.
Um...
Hi, mister.
Uh, caught a giant tuna.
That stone there.
Never mind.
Keep at it.
I arrived in a new area!
You barely made it this far, huh?
Looks like you've got the hang of using that bell now.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
Legally distinct Aeon Mall.
I know, it's a Aquan Mall.
There's a famous mall chain called Aeon Malls in Japan that
kind of use that same font.
Go hauling a bunch in this area too, yeah?
Oh, yes, sir, yes, sir, yes, sir.
So now we should be able to fast travel, which is good.
These guys all look like they're in the air.
not in the water.
Which is exciting.
Oh my gosh, new area!
Yippee!
They're actually kind of slow, so that's nice.
Or they seem slow?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I'm looking at the...
I think I see Chilazar Us.
Wait!
Does that just say Uniclub?
Oh!
Umi-klo!
Yeah, this is all new.
Oh.
There he goes into the wall.
That's clever.
Ha!
I got one!
You're acting like a human now after killing all those fish.
You've watched from the sea.
see.
You know how ugly humans are.
So why?
Why become one of them?
Oh!
6,000!
Oh, heck yeah!
It's not you, fish.
It's the fact that...
It's the fact that you guys give me such sweet cash.
Oh, they're fast in the water, though.
Oh, oops.
they're ginormous yeah you'll see them really fast in the
water and then out of the water they're pretty slow you just
kind of gotta i'm just kind of like holding out for one to
jump by me i'll probably go sell right quick before the mall
i wonder if we'll meet any more well i guess there was the
guy in the seifuku Okay, that one.
A guy in the Seifuku, so...
I imagine there will be another human?
Or fish human?
In here?
Multiple?
Maybe?
Fascinating.
Very, very interesting.
Oh my gosh, please.
So...
12,000!
Yeah, or worse, human fish.
What about the fish here?
Let's see.
Did you know some fish love bright light?
They're usually down on the sea floor, so you might miss
them.
So you should use the sonar.
Also, for flying fish, it's easier to catch them if you
boost.
Oh, okay.
Some fish on the bot...
Wait, I have a sonar?
Isn't that the thing I picked up, but...
It, like, didn't attach to my boat.
I definitely picked one up, though, but it didn't...
Um...
It didn't attach.
I remember grabbing it.
Not yet?
No, I could have sworn it was like...
Outside at the school.
Whoa, this one's nice.
We don't have the sonar yet.
Okay.
I guess we'll go get it.
I have to find a way to get inside here.
Oh, we have the soul!
Not Mujie.
Afternoon drift!
Oh, these are all like just...
You guys hear that?
Oh!
Human.
There's a human shape there.
Big fish.
Big, big fish.
Oh, big fish.
I don't think we can get up there.
Maybe with my boat.
I think if I...
Um, where to jump on top of it.
Ah, dang it.
Wait, you, you, you, you, you.
Ah!
I'm not good at timing it.
It's okay.
We're just driving around right now.
We might be able to get in through here.
This might work.
It shows that there's more than one human here, maybe?
Eh.
If only I were a flying fish.
Okay.
Never mind.
There's more.
So many.
Oops.
So many seashells.
Oh, I did it again.
Okay, hold on.
A little closer.
There we go.
That's good.
No.
Yes.
Yes!
Sonar, eh?
Alright.
I'm just struggling to find a way inside.
First of all.
I'm struggling to get it.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I think here is our entrance.
Follow the yellow gamer paint.
In this case, the yellow gamer cones.
Oh, is this the sonar?
Ah!
Updated.
Oh, no, that's the map.
Oh, that's what I was thinking of.
It was the map, I suppose.
I thought that was a sonar.
Kind of feels sonar-esque because it told us the location of
that one guy, right?
Why is the music so creepy in here?
Hello?
It's just a takoyaki, no?
Do I look like...
Do I look like a lost child in the woods?
Yo, can you give me a...
I wanted Dunkin' Donuts today, but I resisted.
Stop.
If you get Dunkin' Donuts, I'll get Dunkin' Donuts.
Hello.
This guy looks like Astarian from Baldur's Gate.
Takoyaki guy.
Octopus?
Where is the octopus?
Who cares about anything else?
live life eating only octopus there was nothing else to eat
out there i was desperate i was fighting to survive to eat
equals to live that's all there was to stay alive i ate
octopus like my life depended on it because it did and now i
can't live without them anymore there's nothing in these by
the way japanese hysterian who makes takoyaki
Oh my gosh, this A, this AU is crazy.
They really just be putting characters in any situations
nowadays.
My head is nothing but the eight-legged.
Can't think about anything else, and nothing else moves my
heart like the octopus.
Alright, you can like, you can replace this with the
two-legged.
Can't think of anything else.
Nothing else moves my heart like the minto.
maybe my whole life is going to be nothing but minto ah
minto my one and only minto that writhing body wait a second
the graceful way she changes shape every form is beautiful
you make me want to know more everything about you there's
nothing else like her I want to see her up close touch her
and make her mine mine alone okay never mind I think the
audio The dialogue got a little funky.
You know what?
What should I say to her?
How should I act?
Am I mad enough?
Sounds like the old guy at the nearby parking lot has
something that can help you find the octopus.
But I don't want to leave the octopus aside.
Oh, yeah.
Yay, yeah.
Get back in there.
Yeah, flip those balls.
Flip those balls.
Oh, new paint.
I want to go to the army.
Oh, the mannequin in the water is scary.
That's pretty freaky.
Cute.
I like how the shells even have different designs on the
back, you know.
Easter egg, Easter egg.
Umiclo.
I don't know.
Okay, I'm going to save and then we'll do this.
Did I just save this one, right?
Oh, oops.
That's a money, money, money.
Follow the money.
Find the sonar at the parking lot.
Wait, I didn't see this one.
Cute.
Guys, this is an obvious trap.
This is an obvious trap.
What if it was a cute girl saying all that about you?
How can I resist?
Oh, it's funny.
Oh my god, the mannequins are so scary.
How do the plants live?
Nothing happened.
Did I not go down far enough?
Is that something?
You heard that.
Totally safe.
Hmm.
What's this?
I don't trust...
It's so funny because there's the spooky atmosphere of the
game and then it's like, oh by the way, thank you to our
Patreon!
Thank you to our patrons!
Check out this cute little seashell!
Umikuro!
Who's in the water?
The mannequins?
Manikins are in the water.
Drift on.
I don't know what that one is a...
Is a...
reference to.
Was there some?
No, I think...
I thought I saw something in the water, but I think I'm just
seeing, like, the light reflection.
Hmm.
Yeah?
What's in here?
Oh, they're all clothes.
Oh, oh, this is, I think it's another way to get up.
Oh!
You're real.
There's another way to get out of the water.
Oh, my God.
Hold on.
I'm getting all the seashells by the seashore before...
All the shoes.
All right.
Isn't it kind of amazing how I'm going all out with my
fashion just to get that Takoyaki guy next door to notice
me?
Is that a hole in her dress?
Or is that her hair clipping through?
It almost looks like gills or something.
Like when I first saw him, it was instant.
Total spark.
But then, ugh, he's obsessed with that octopus and he never
looks my way.
Isn't that messed up?
I need to get more stuff.
I'll get his attention for sure.
And like people in this world, their brains are basically
99% food.
Especially that octopus.
Even him, he's all octo-o-o.
Like, gross.
It camouflages and pops up out of nowhere, too.
Literally the worst.
Total nuisance.
Oh, that sounds like it'll be fun.
I want everything, but that octopus keeps ruining my plan.
If there was some way to get rid of it.
I'd owe you my life.
Hey, can you take that octopus down?
I feel like you can handle it.
And the way you keep pushing forward, I genuinely respect
that.
Money.
The money is flying in front of me.
Get rid of the octopus.
And I'll give you something good, I swear.
And me, someday, I'll...
This dress is standing up all on its own.
World's stiffest dress ever.
Holy moly.
I don't think I see anything in the water.
I'm gonna save again though.
By sheer willpower.
Yeah, it's ultimately, ultimate starched.
Starched dress.
Okay, okay.
Knee boat.
uh oh i did sell those guys okay i was like wait a second i
don't know if i sold them and they disappeared i'd be so sad
so we gotta go to the parking lot i feel like we probably
have enough money to get there but then apparently there's
an octopus that might um that might sabotage us so let's
mark our map there and go go go just saved but i'll save
again while we're in the boat right all right can't it's not
bad to be cautious you know oh like i see stuff on the
bottom floor like that what is that oh you also get spooked
for me oh man okay
good to know
there's like all this I was gonna say garbage it's just a
bunch of this is half fuel does this look like half fuel to
you guys what I like how this is the parking lot that's
pretty funny this is half fuel no just a guy I love the
pictures of just a guy guy is this like is that a rock or
okay yeah huh oh oh pink actually pink what the oh I thought
the guy disappeared oh that's paint it seems trying
to see like what I see in the underwater you know oh I think
that big guy's coming back oh I I see him, I see him!
The little baby hand is what's getting me.
Why the heck is that?
Oh, it's only a thousand yen.
Oh!
Oh, it has a face!
It has a human face!
Okay, we'll keep going for the flying fish.
Ugh.
I once saw a really strange human a long time ago.
Couldn't even swim, but he drove his car straight into the
sea.
I thought, what an idiot.
But now I think I understand him a little.
Fish are free.
In that wide ocean, they go anywhere.
Ah, sorry.
But what about humans?
Stuck on land.
Your world's so small.
That's why humans drive cars, I guess.
It's like swimming in the sea.
You swim across land for freedom.
If I can get this car fixed, maybe I'll be free again, too.
Hey, you.
The fish around here stole all four tires off my car.
Sorry to ask, but could you bring them back for me?
Okay, okay.
So we gotta...
Oh, he's got the sonar!
Okay, all right.
How do I...
Oh.
Place tire?
Ooh.
Nasty.
I know, we're fixing up his K truck.
Can I have it?
Can I have a...
Just, can I...
I think I see two other ones even.
Oh, okay.
I have to grab them both.
It seems.
Why?
How did they...
How did they steal these?
Ew.
How did they steal the...
the tires of the...
That's a love that's concerning me.
With their weird little hands.
Oh, gross.
There is so icky.
It'd be nice if I could, like, steal some gasoline for my
boat, you know.
They do look happy.
Maybe life as a fish is better.
Who knows?
He didn't warn me about these things.
The guy at the gasoline place.
Oh, thanks.
Now I'm free again.
You're not gonna drive it into the ocean.
Oh, that's my... Oh.
How long does it stay down there for?
The whole time?
Yay!
Oh, it spooked me.
Defeat the disguised octopus in the mall.
In the mall.
Right, there's quite a bit of fish around there.
Like, uh, the flying guys.
Of the flying variety.
So I want to see if we can capture some.
Um.
Upgrade a little.
Oh, that was so close.
I feel.
Maybe he was too far.
Wow!
The sky's octopus.
Decoy octopus!
This game was maybe meant...
Oh, meant for me.
Yes!
Yes.
Big money.
Yes, big money.
My boat's getting a little full.
A little fall, a little fall.
I don't think I can get that guy.
I think that guy's up.
Jump!
Jump in front of me!
Somebody!
Somebody, somewhere!
Jump in front of me, please.
It's too quiet.
I don't even see anything like at the bottom of the sea.
Oh.
Ah!
And...
Ha!
Oh.
Okay.
Let's go back.
The big shellfish into that.
That's too good.
The sun is...
Oh, not the sun.
Sorry.
The moon is moving so fast.
Okay.
Hello, sir.
I have some fish for you.
Anything I can... I can upgrade my harpoon twice.
Aim speed.
Wait, what does that mean?
I thought that's... Is that not me?
Oh, I think like with how fast it like kind of does a... You
know.
Let's do that.
And let's do the range.
I think those are pretty big points.
Let's also remember to have enough money to refuel.
I just need so much money now.
Like crazy buku bucks, you know?
Oh, it is pretty...
Dang it!
The real is, the real end is not ideal either, I'll be
honest, but...
Wait, it was... Oh, here.
There we go.
Yeah!
Maybe the octopus will be worth a lot.
Yeah, let's get to it.
But also, what is the sonar for?
There's like so much... Oh, oopsie.
Oh, please, please.
Thank you.
Oh, this is just a tuna.
These guys are around here too.
Nah.
Too.
Anybody?
I think he's going too far away.
That's all right.
We're looking around for any others.
I'm not even gonna bother with the tunas, I'm not gonna lie.
I'm sorry!
Plop!
Slap it on the ground, slap it on the ground.
Oh my gosh, can you imagine?
I think, oh, it was too far away anyway.
It's hard to tell sometimes.
Okay, I'm gonna sell these before I forget, and then we'll
also save.
I'm not good at timing it at all.
He threw it on the ground.
Sell, please.
Shop.
Sell, sell, sell!
Nice.
What are we at?
I think we should focus on the boat Because we'll need boat
speed to get to the next area
Probably Oh my god 30,000 Okay, let's do the octopus
Which is what?
Defeat the disguise octopus It's in the mall it says So It
says we need a sonar for it but oh my god okay fine fine
fine i give
up i give up oh wait maybe i go oh like in here
oh i think
i saw it
Oh, the sound effects are...
The worst, maybe.
The sound effects are maybe so terrible.
I don't see it, though.
Let me point directly at it.
I'm afraid to get too close.
Do you guys see it?
Up, maybe?
You think it's like up there?
Oh, it's so bad.
Ew, I just drive past really fast.
Oh, I see it!
It's on the, oh my gosh, it's on the umi- the umi-kudo.
Oh, that's so funny!
Okay.
Oh, it's close again.
So it's like a distorted version of something that it's
disguised as.
It says it's right in front of me again.
It's so hard to see.
Ew.
Is it this?
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Oh, that was just a thing in the- okay.
The pillar!
I didn't even notice that the pillar was a thing.
Okay.
Or wasn't a thing.
That's so funny.
Oh, over here.
Oh!
Please update, okay.
Okay.
Oh, it's so freaky.
Minto, I'm scared.
Is that her?
It
says that it's the octopus though.
Or is this it right there?
Oh no!
Oh geez.
That's not good.
That doesn't seem good.
We're getting out.
What's that on top of me?
Wait, what's that on top of me?
Oh, oh, oh!
Talk to I do!
I think we have more pressing matters!
Oh, guys, Jaws was just coming after me!
Sorry, sorry, mister.
That was freaky.
I don't know if I was supposed to shoot it or what.
Thanks for taking the octopus down.
I really thought if it was gone, he'd finally look my way.
Well, a promise is a promise.
Here, this is for you.
Thank you!
One more bell.
Is it still in there, I wonder?
No.
I think we just made him mad.
Sorry, mister.
Sorry about that.
Alright, that means just one more area, right?
But we gotta fish a lot.
We gotta upgrade our...
We gotta really lock in on these fish so we can upgrade our
boat.
Defeated the octopus.
So you took the octopus down, huh?
Did you meet the Takoyaki guy?
His obsession with the octopus was rather intense.
When he took her down, something in him snapped.
At first, I thought his instincts just snapped.
But this is way beyond hangry.
Maybe some kind of hot emotion got mixed in, too.
Like a lust?
He turned into a shark, huh?
His feelings were so strong, it turned right in front of
you.
I've never seen that before.
Oh, well, not our problem, right?
Let's just keep fishing like always.
I brought back two bells was it two bells I marked the new
places good luck oh wait there is this area too just kidding
oh we had two I didn't realize it was two bells uh oh wait
that means it's gonna be like really big oh that's no good
okay awesome I guess not you know I guess in that new the
newer area we'll get another piece and then in the last area
we'll get a piece most likely but we we can't do anything
until we get level three most likely so oh let's lock in
gamers let's lock I'm not half fuel don't lie to me I said
there was stuff at the bottom of the sea oh yes oh my god i
didn't think i was gonna get that one
that used the sonar to find it but like what
yes oh yeah let's save the game true true true
what about the giant guy i wonder if we could get him i was
thinking that too i feel like i cheesed the other guy maybe
this guy's I mean he seems slower because he's massive we
could try why not I do feel like though the these these guys
are like kind of the way to go I don't want to waste fuel
trying to chase after the big guy you know what I mean ah
he was
I imagine he's probably worth like 50,000 if I had to guess
if I had to guess
hold on I'm gonna have a sweater on and I'm taking it off
you'd guess 80k 80k oh I don't Oh, he might have a tablet
though.
You're right.
Oh, you're right.
Okay, okay.
You're right.
Let's go.
Get our dino.
Fish.
Where is he anyway?
Okay, she's like out this way.
This way.
Oh, I'm gonna save.
Just in case.
He, um, like, attacks.
And our little boat can't take it.
Our little poor boat.
Oh, the lighting, like, freaks me out.
Okay.
I'm getting old and forgetting things.
Forgot why the world is flooded.
Forgot why we are hunting sakanas.
Forgot why there is giant sakana chasing us outside of safe
areas.
Cubay?
You are not old.
None of that has been explained.
Quite literally, I have no idea.
Quite literally, I couldn't tell you.
Wait, this goes out kind of far, no?
Oh, there he is, there he is.
This thing is huge.
This guy is big.
Maybe I have to get his...
eyes or something.
Like that.
Ah,
okay, okay, okay.
It's probably like a get him multiple times kind of
scenario.
Okay, this away, this away, this away.
My gas though!
This is pretty tough, I feel.
Okay, we'll do our best.
He's just a peaceful guy.
Yeah, but I crave cash.
Money hungry people are not peaceful.
Lesson learned.
Oh, he's far.
He's far away.
Oh, he's quite far.
What the heck?
Why is it telling me now I'm just at the mall?
Is he outside the...
Scope?
Oh, he's in this area!
Oh, I just realized!
Okay, so we got him for...
This time...
Oh, I'm stupid.
I don't even notice.
Okay, well, um...
Well, we got him for this area, so we go to the next...
That means I gotta keep fishing.
Uh-oh.
How do I get to the rooftop?
We still haven't been able to.
It has to be away.
It has to be.
Trying to get on top of my boat.
And then use...
I wish I could double jump.
I know I have to keep playing the game.
No.
Maybe this side over here.
I didn't see any shops that we could go.
into at all.
This one looks even taller.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
No,
I don't think so.
All right, let's go fishing.
Fish at the bottom of the water.
We could try over here.
Seem to be fish around these parts.
Oh, oops.
Oh, there were two of them, though.
No, we had our chance.
We had our chance.
It's easier to see them, too, around here, so it's...
little nicer.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, gosh, they're so fast.
Holy moly.
I really thought maybe we had a chance at that one.
They are just zooming.
Oh, to be a flying.
Fish.
Seems kind of fun.
Best of both worlds, right?
Oh.
Ah!
Please!
This would make a great friend slop game.
You think so?
Hmm.
Oh, dang it.
I missed him.
Ha!
Oh, I knew it.
I knew it.
I stood as I did it.
I was like, no, there's no way.
Ah!
Yes.
The thing is, is I feel like there's so many fishing friend
swap games, which I'm not complaining because like I said, I
love me some fish.
I love fishing.
We should not wish fishing.
And this is a little different from fishing.
It's harpooning.
I have to be FPS master to do it.
But...
That is what it is.
What is Umigari and never heard of it?
It's the newest Chillas art game.
Where we are in a mysterious flooded world where human are
fish and fish are human.
And so technically these fish that were like...
Harpooning here could be human.
And I think I'm a fish.
I just noticed.
I think their wings are hands, aren't they?
Literally my point.
I said could be.
They are human.
This is a great spot, you guys.
What the?
Who were you?
I wasn't even paying attention to you.
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Oh, this is a new one.
holy oh it's only 3 000 yen though yeah going for the fast
guys seems to be the best easiest way to get money oh that
is oh oh i kind of want to see its face better oh maybe i
don't want to see its face the ear i don't know what it is
but the ears are the things that are disturbing me the most
about it
Don't like that!
My radar is showing like no fish.
Where'd they go?
Have I...
Have I taken all the fish in the whole world?
The whole sea?
Nothing else is... Okay, well...
For now we'll just uh...
We'll drive away and we'll go sell what we got.
Stay, hang in there, fish.
Hang in there.
I have to fill up anyway, so...
Alrighty.
Hello, I'm here.
Alright, my hall is massive this time.
I try to jump off of that every time and I miss.
Please, sir.
Can I have a hand?
27,000.
We can get the boat speed.
I almost want to get that and then the harpoon reel.
I'm like debating about the boost.
I can't even...
Oh, sonar scans.
Oh, wow.
The boost?
Like, you can't even use it in the bell areas, so...
What will the fuel capacity be after that then?
Holy cow!
Hmm.
I want the harpoon reel.
We can get...
a few more here.
Oh, uh...
Holy cow, that used so much...
Okay, never mind.
I changed my mind.
What is... why does the E mean?
What does the E mean?
Ah!
Oh, it was that... Oh, okay.
The wings are definitely hands in the budget dredge games.
It makes me wonder if Chilla's art took inspiration for
Black Salt games.
If so, I like.
Maybe, maybe.
Uh, okay.
That's fine.
We just leave here.
As travel to First Island.
Alright.
Hokey-dokey!
I think that's our place down there.
Yes, sir.
This away!
And once I get closer to the Tori, I will...
save
truly i walk on nine
all right yes let's go let's go
okay i
actually missed the sign Are you okay?
We're fine.
I did miss, but I saved it.
I saved the run.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, here it is.
Oh!
I was about to say, we're not gonna make it!
We're not gonna make it!
We made it!
It has to be designed like that, right?
Where are we at?
Is this a hospital?
Don't tell me.
Spooky.
Oh, head to...
No way!
Dome!
Like a... It does kind of look like a Tokyo Dome.
I'm not gonna lie.
Hello!
Excuse me.
Stop sneezing and being disgusting.
Um, how do you usually get from place to place?
But listen, I put together an organization so we can work
together and survive this world.
If you see my people in trouble, I'd be happy if you lend
them a hand.
Wait, that didn't answer or anything.
The dome.
What about the fish here?
Down here, they are lurking on the sea floor.
You'll think, no way I can catch it down there, right?
That's when you should use bait.
But there's a fish that'll mess with you, so be careful.
It spits out ink and turns everything black.
When that fish isn't around, do the best... That's the best
time to use bait.
Don't waste it, okay?
I don't have any bait.
Get baited?
So it says the dome first, so let's go to the dome, and
let's also save.
I can't even see anything.
Ophish.
Lucky guess.
Dang.
Can you imagine?
What are you?
Oh, you're really not going to stop.
You're gonna say it's for the good of the world, aren't you?
What a joke.
I know what you really are.
This isn't duty, it's pleasure.
It's cruel, isn't it?
How the world turns you into the very thing you hated?
The second you're on top.
How much are you worth?
Big money!
I'm just selling it so that we can go over to the actually I
will get the harpoon reel now though look at that the reel
in is important because I feel like you then can move on to
another fish faster you know what I mean there's a boat over
here you could probably bait the fish by winking and
giggling at them.
A little fish!
Ah!
Oh no, that's not a big fish.
Oh, big fish.
That's not a big fish.
Wait, that's a big fish?
Oh that's the inky one!
That's the inky one.
Ooh, there's a light on in there.
Creepy.
Okay, anyway.
Someone's boat, eh?
Head to Dome.
I'm here.
Look, they have a whole fleet!
Wait, the music's cool.
Hello!
Man, this is bad.
Oh, is he a fish?
The guy who was in charge of catching fish disappeared at
the nearby dorm.
He took the bait machine with him.
I can't make any deliveries without it.
Wait a second.
Let me get a closer look at you.
Oh!
He's wearing a disguise!
It's a mask!
Oh my god.
Wait, what the heck?
Fish.
So we gotta go to the dorm over there, huh?
Oh, next time we go to the...
Is this supposed to be Tokyo Dome?
Next time we go back to the gas station, we'll,
uh...
Oops.
Getting all top.
Whoa!
Do you see how many fish are in there?
Can I have a bite?
Please, uh, spare me one fish.
Lisa, a single fish.
We'll change my boat color is what I've been trying to say.
Maybe I can...
Wait, maybe I can get in like this.
Watch this.
We're gonna get in.
We're gonna get into the dome.
Alright, use your arms.
Use your arms.
You're a human.
You're a human now.
The door, man.
All right, metal gear style.
All right, I'm definitely going to save because I'm scared.
I keep creating new ones because I'm lazy-ish.
Oh, no, this is not a lie.
It's a seashell.
Chicken.
All right.
Oh, here we are.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, it's scary.
Am I gonna be fighting things in here with my harpoon?
That's what I'm worried about.
Hello, Mr. Baitman!
The man with the bait!
Oh, the water's all funky here.
It's dark!
For a ghost you're rather cowardly.
What are you talking about?
I deal with a paranormal, not fish!
I don't deal...
What the heck is that?
Ah!
Wait, I think I just got punched in the head.
Wait, what just happened?
Wait a second.
What just happened?
Maybe I was supposed to spear him.
Wait a second.
I don't know, actually, what is supposed to happen.
Oh, I got attacked from behind!
That's what happened!
Oh, my God.
There really are guys attacking me here.
No.
Oh, geez.
Wait, I said I could open this.
Is that going to go?
Now it's gone.
Wait.
There's a shale.
Okay.
Oh, man.
I kind of hear them, like, coming up, though.
Or at least I did.
Please.
Mr. The water is being funky here.
Oh, that don't look good.
Oh, is he alive?
Oh, I think he's alive.
Wow, this place is...
That kind of does look like a prison, though.
It's such a small apartment.
I can get him from here.
Yeah, that's right.
Mito is the one who knocks.
I am the one who knocks.
Oh, hold on.
Let's save real quick.
I know one of these rooms was gonna jump scare us like
crazy.
I don't like it in here.
I don't like it one bit.
I wish I could, like, have my harpoon, like, armed, and also
open doors.
He's probably in here, right?
Are you in here?
Oh.
A guy is in here.
What am I saying?
Why are you posed like that?
I don't know what I'm looking for here.
I'm a little...
We're looking for a guy with a bait machine?
I can't go up anymore either, so...
Guy with the bait machine.
Okay, we're on 7.
Sorry, I keep making through saves.
Oh, there's more blood there.
Oye, oye, oye, oye, oye, oye, oye.
Oh!
Suddenly it's a zombie game.
Suddenly playing Half-Life.
Ew, nasty.
Sneak attack!
Is that him down there?
Might be.
Might be, might be.
I hear one walking.
Oh, there he is!
They're kind of slow, which is nice.
They're a little slow.
I can't see in here.
I don't like that.
Ooh.
Just making sure he's dead.
Finishing the job.
How's the fishing?
We're...
Ah!
He got me from behind!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You can't have me going through all that again.
Quick load.
What?
Why?
No!
Oh, why?
Save six?
Yeah, this is a save six.
I mean, it's not that I'm...
Wait, but my money...
Was I only at 2700?
I don't know.
I don't remember what my money was at.
No way.
Yeah, it shows that we've been to the area even.
Oh, what?
Do I, can I at least fast travel to it?
Probably.
Yeah, we can.
Okay, not all is lost.
I'm just annoyed.
Let's, uh...
Oh, cute!
Whoa!
Let's do the pink boat.
What's the red boat?
Ooh.
Go back to save seven then?
I guess so, yeah.
Load.
I hope I don't have to do the whole...
What's it called?
Oh, those guys again.
Yeah, so you save seven and kiss the zombies you killed,
save the...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's true.
Think.
Ah, what the heck?
What the heck?
What's the point of saving then?
Whoa, wait, is that a big guy?
yes it is you know what wait I'm confused actually I'm
actually kind of wait hold on I think there's another big
guy over there about the fish here oh my bad sorry my bad I
think I got him oh good we can get a couple of these guys I
don't I'm kind of confused, but...
Wait, wait.
Oh, I think I grabbed them both.
My bad.
I'm a little confused.
If...
This shows...
I don't remember how much money I had, must have I think.
I don't remember how much money I had.
Don't get too close to me, though.
Which is holding harpoon.
Yeah, for real.
Oh, oops, wait, hold on.
Upgrade.
Oh, my bad.
Sorry.
Upgrade.
Okay, so my harpoon reel.
Okay, I guess I did have just that much money.
Hmm.
Okay.
Okay, I guess I did spend a lot of it.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I had upgraded the harpoon reel.
Okay.
How...
How could this happen to me?
Yes.
These guys are good money, so...
Might as well grab them when I see them.
I really hope those guys don't respawn.
Because they scare me.
Okay.
They scare me!
Okay, what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna save out here.
I guess I save over this one, it doesn't even matter.
I save out here.
And...
I don't know.
Who knows?
There's like something out, like...
I saw the fins out of the water.
I'm just gonna go to the second story.
And hope that that's where...
I needed to go to.
There's a lighthouse over there!
You guys see that?
Interesting.
All the doors are shut.
I sure hope not.
It didn't save.
Oh, it didn't save in here.
No.
Why?
There was a guy behind me even!
Oh!
Where did that guy come from?
Where did you come from?
Holy cow!
Okay.
So there's a guy over here.
Is there another guy?
Huh!
I hear it!
Okay.
I was like I I know I know your games I feel like it's that
guy I feel like that's the bait thing at the very end I
don't know I have a feeling but I'm like I know a guy comes
out I just don't know where and when you know oh I hear him
there he is oh there he is okay i've played these games
before okay gotta
look over my back at everything man it was like around here
that i got god
maybe i lied oh my god it's a seashell no way maybe we go up
from here okay
This area is stressing me out Because now I know if I die I
have to do everything again
Okay, some guy's gonna pop out of there
I'm paranoid as hell At least this room is nice and bright
Lovely Lovely
Chula usually isn't this cruel.
It might be like a genuine mistake.
Okay, that's the thing.
Like a genuine bug.
Bait machine, use a fish to produce bait.
The fish will be lost.
Can I have my...
Thank you.
I nope the heck.
out of there.
I absolutely no shame.
Said no way Jose.
Alright, now we need to find a normal fish, huh?
But also,
wasn't I supposed to bring that...
Wait, what happened to your guy then?
I just... I just... I don't even check.
Okay.
Ew!
What is this?
Is this the bait?
Wait a second.
Oh, wait.
I feel it.
I fear I am in the way of this lovely creature.
Only 3,000!
Oh, it looks like a... Is this the bait?
What am I supposed to do?
do with this.
I don't want it.
I don't want it on my ship.
And I guess he's the one that ink set up, it looks like.
Yeah, he's an inky guy.
If I look at him.
I- what am I supposed to do with these?
Maybe I grab them.
Oh, okay, okay.
Any guys coming around?
Oh.
Let's go to...
Let's go a little forward.
Like here.
Oh.
You're an inky guy.
Get out of here.
You're not allowed to eat my bait.
Oh, stop it!
Stop it!
Stop coming to my bait!
I'm getting baited.
We'll go out a little bit more.
Oh, I see, like, sometimes I see, like, fins and stuff.
I saw one way, way in the distance, too.
Okay, these are the, these are the heavy hitters.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we need more of you guys.
Come back, come back, please!
You're still hungry!
We have some inky guys too we can use.
Yes.
Inky.
Yeah, inky guys for bait.
Maybe someone else will show up before it disappears.
Coming once.
Going twice.
Alright, throw!
Oh, oh my god, they're so fast!
I think I...
It's kind of hard because you don't throw it very far.
Like, even when I hold it down.
Like, I'm not throwing it super far.
You know?
Alright.
Come here!
Let me just sell what I got, man.
Maybe the angle matters.
Maybe, maybe.
I like how the sky just sometimes decides to change to a
different image.
Just classic Chilizard.
Okay, select all and sell.
We're...
We're doing so bad.
Guys, this is so bad.
The grind is like crazy now.
That's what sucks.
The grind is kind of insane now.
Hello, hello, I'm back.
Oh, okay.
That's the bait maker for catching fish.
Wait, are you the one the boss mentioned?
Perfect timing.
I'm glad you showed up.
The boss?
Could you help us with deliveries?
I want you to load 10 fish from inside this dome onto each
of the three boats.
You're a lifesaver.
Okay.
Wait, so what is it?
Load 10 fish from the dome onto each of the three boats.
Wait, are these...
These are the blobfish!
Okay.
Wait, so I need 10 on each boat?
This really is Tokyo Dome.
It's so funny.
They're just little blobfish.
Can I sell these guys at all?
They don't have a price, so probably...
Oh, sorry.
I'm not keeping count.
I'm just murdering.
I'm just going on a spree.
Killing spree.
I see a shell over there.
They're called goblin fish.
Ah.
Goblin fish.
The ones that aren't supposed to look like this, but because
they're used to living under such severe pressure when you
take them out of it.
Or it's either the pressure or just the water itself.
I can't remember.
I wish I could get two at once.
Wish came true.
Yeah,
baby.
Oh, they're only...
Oh, they are only one yen, it does say.
Yeah, okay.
I know, the music's so chill in this area.
So chillas.
You think I have enough?
No.
Oh, it is cheap bait, you're right!
And easy to catch too!
Let's go put some of these guys away.
My boat's gonna be filled with them.
Who's buying this many of them?
See, there's a fin!
Oh, I think I got it, whatever it was.
Oh, it's one of these guys!
Okay, cool.
We do, we do one.
Okay, so one, one, two.
One, two, three.
Oh, four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Okay.
There he goes, there he goes.
Hello?
I wonder if I could like go with them.
Just sail.
How many was that?
Four?
I think.
The silence between five and eight.
I know what I'm doing.
I'm a professional.
I feel like I feel like I should keep some of these guys
though.
Like I should just catch a blind and keep some.
Unless they don't close the gate.
That would be pretty nice too.
One,
two, three, four, five.
Fish.
Six fish.
One half fuel.
Okay, okay.
What are they gonna give me for this, huh?
Oh.
I can't.
I can't jump.
I'm stuck.
I'm stuck!
One, two.
You son of a bitch.
Why?
Why did he fall?
No!
I got him!
Never mind, he didn't fall!
He's still here!
He's still here.
Okay.
Okay!
Nice!
Oh, I was about to be so sad!
You're a lifesaver!
So you really are the person Boss talked so highly about.
Oh, we get the bell!
Go for it!
Oops.
Oh, we got three bells this time.
Crazy.
And we also can't forget that this massive guy is in this
area as well.
And there's the lighthouse over there.
Oh, you can watch them like sail off.
That's kind of cute.
Nice save.
Thank you.
Brought back three bells.
Go attach it.
This guy is so fast.
Mark their new location.
Do your best.
Wait, what?
That's, it's not here?
How long is this game?
Wait, what?
Weeks are fun, weeks are fun.
You heard six hours?
Holy cow.
Fumoku took five hours.
I've never done a part two.
on of Chilla's art game before.
I've never...
I had stuff to do tonight, though.
That's my issue.
I thought it was going to be like a three-hour game like
they usually were.
I guess it also depends on how you like upgrade your stuff,
you know?
And things like that.
Oh, let me get fuel real quick, actually.
Stop, stop.
That was bamboozled.
That's what I get for playing a game that just comes out
immediately and not like, you know, waiting to see how long
other people take to play it.
You know, that's my fault for just being...
Oh, I think it's outside the...
It is outside the line, though.
Very interesting.
Hello!
Come back!
So are you.
Hi!
Where are you?
Whoa!
Hello?
Where's your eyeball at?
Suspicious?
Oh, suspicious.
That's where we've been.
Hello!
Where's your eyeball?
That one right there?
This way.
Where the heck are you?
Am I blind?
Clearly I am.
What?
This way.
I see it.
Wait, I thought I saw it.
There.
No, please!
No, I did.
There we go.
Yay!
Alright.
quite well.
All the way to the new area.
Oh, we gotta buy the new speed.
We gotta buy the new speed, but we're gonna lose out on the
fuel capacity.
We're like, yeah, so we'll have less fuel.
This is tricky.
Yeah, it's only 150k.
Yeah, no big deal.
Wait, are these the blobfish?
What are you guys doing out?
Wait, did they escape?
Did they escape?
Okay, hold on.
Let's try this.
Oh, dang it.
That was a waste.
Wasn't it?
They're gathering!
Oh, they're worth 2,000!
Okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
The blobs escaped containment.
It's kind of horrible.
Stop eating it.
Oh, I see one, I see one.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh my god, these are the stinking.
I can't see anything now.
sacrifice
where are you where are you big guy come on come on no way
I'm gonna move a little bit away where are you and I'm so
Soul gray.
Yes.
Ha!
I think that's him down there.
I think that's actually him down there.
Unless I be crazy.
It looks like him, no?
Does that not look like the fish?
You know what, no.
Even though you're worth more, you piss me off.
You piss me off.
Yes, it is him.
I knew it!
I knew it was him!
Oh, I knew it.
Oh, I knew it was him.
Oh, my gosh.
That's crazy.
Whoa!
I could see him.
My eyes!
Fishing eyes are trained for this.
I'm not letting you.
Wait.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh, I have this guy too.
Alright, let's just drive back.
What do you see with your mint eyes?
I am the chosen one!
Yes!
Alright, we're getting some good cash here.
Excuse me, I do need a drive though.
Everybody in?
This guy scared me.
We'll figure it out.
Ew, I just noticed his nose.
It's like a people nose.
Yeah, we're just going to carry these.
I actually am holding on to five guys.
Five guys.
Oh, I do need to put you on my boat, don't I?
Very nice.
I'm getting hungry even.
Okay, we just need 50,000 more.
Maybe it is okay.
Oh, I don't think I'm ever gonna get my boost up or
anything.
Bait range.
Interesting.
I want to increase my fuel capacity, but I don't know.
Just got back from Dunkin' Donuts!
I'm hungry.
I'm hungry, ghost.
I cannot possess or eat your sacrifices.
When I am...
When I am streaming!
Is there anything out here?
Hungry ghost.
Ghost is hungry.
Still have two hours left of work.
You got this!
I think I have two hours left of gaming.
Oh no, I'm not gonna be able to make it to this store
tonight.
Ah!
Make a part two?
I might have to.
I might just do this game again in the middle of the day.
This seems like such a waste.
It's not even that long of a game.
I don't know.
Are you guys fine with a part two?
First Chillas part two.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
You can just yapp up through.
That's true, that's true.
Okay.
Let me save.
I'm so sorry, you guys.
I honestly...
I don't know what I was thinking.
I was like, oh, it's going to be done in like three hours.
Easy peasy.
I was like, yeah, whatever.
So easy.
So I apologize.
I will do a part two.
I might even do it tonight if I feel like it.
Uh...
Shit.
Sorry, I'm just so busy.
I'm like, thinking of all that I gotta do.
I don't think.
Actually, maybe I can't do it tonight.
We'll do it tomorrow, same time as today, before
contradiction.
Contradiction is tomorrow, right?
Yes.
So let me put that on my calendar.
Umigari 2.
Okay.
I'll do this tomorrow.
Again.
Sure thing, boss.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Thank you for fishing.
Good luck with what you have to do tonight.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Thank you, Trey Princess.
Why are you sorry?
a very long game, but I'm making a part two, so I feel silly
about it, but, um, it's not very long, but I'm making a part
two, so I feel goofy about it.
But anyway, I'm going to go eat, and I'm going to go do what
I need to do.
And I will see you guys when I see you next.
We'll yapp, we'll yapp tomorrow, and I'll do this in
contradiction, and I'm taking tomorrow off.
Possess me for more doughnuts.
Yippee!
Thank you!
Come on!
Thanks for fishing with me.
Thank you, thank you.
Ochamito, ochamito, ochamito!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.
Thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye, bye-bye.